[Music]
hello and welcome to this video on
DevOps orchestration in this video we
will cover the following what is
automation and orchestration why does
the industry need DevOps orchestration
how to relate DevOps with orchestration
the key benefits of DevOps orchestration
the investments and technology stack
required for orchestration and an
example of a success story
DevOps teams would like to move fast and
would want to ship faster but most
organizations would want to build up
tools to allow sharing across teams and
to gain an understanding of scale this
is where automation and orchestration
play a key role it ensures that they are
straight all of these tools in efficient
and easy to review way so what is
automation and orchestration to
repeatedly perform a task or combine
several processes to complete performing
a task is what automation does though
automation is a complex process in scope
it works
on accomplishing a single task like
deploying a server on the other hand
orchestration is more than just
combining the little tasks and
performing a larger script then small
tasks are put together into a workflow
by orchestration services then includes
many of the automation tasks keeping in
mind the steps that might streamline the
workflow task automation is perfect for
improving numerous steps in one area and
does not comply once you move beyond
that particular area this process of the
movement of the product through multiple
departments from the beginning to
completion state is called a workflow IT
and applications make use of the same
logic as not everything that is related
to technology can be put on the ID now
why does the industry need DevOps
orchestration the industry will be able
to gain the following using DevOps
orchestration manage and enforce the
coding standards guidelines and
conventions identify build and deploy
release tools for quicker or faster
releases to improve the release process
and
have error-free releases to define
control and maintain third-party
software and his versions across
environments define and enforce
performance and load at customer or
service level the IT culture has changed
after the introduction of DevOps as it
combines the work of the developers
operations and Quality Assurance testers
to improve the quality of the end result
traditionally the barrier that existed
among these groups has restricted
automation efforts therefore in a DevOps
environment service orchestration has
proved to be the most beneficial to an
organization orchestration has been
built in a way that allows it to work
within the barriers and above them
DevOps team has to coordinate among
themselves as well as employ various
tools this is precisely where
orchestration comes in extracting the
portions of automation from the
weightiest DevOps toolkits this means
that the internal change in a DevOps
team can be a gradual process while
orchestration services can take
advantage of the interfaces that are
already available teams can set
long-term goals that include taking up
the original tool sets that the
orchestration provides this ensures that
the team can prevent the rip and replace
method that prevails in IT service
delivery this also removes the added
effort of having to stop and recreate
everything from scratch by allowing the
team to quickly create automation tasks
and integrate them into an orchestration
platform applying orchestration in
DevOps makes it smooth to shift the
focus to the tasks that are critical
when the developer requests for a
resource and gets it approved the
resources are made available through
automation after deploying the source it
is networked and deployed again with the
required software through automation
that the orchestration controls then via
automation the virtualized resource is
added to the monitoring toolkit which is
again under the orchestrations control
in this way it is very clear that
orchestration controls the work of
automation
some of the key benefits of DevOps
orchestration our problems are solved
faster complexities are easily managed
software delivery is more continuous
there is a higher engagement among
employees more opportunities are
available for professional development
there will be more productive teams
separate tools performing different
functions are joined together by a
pocket straighten it sets up security
checkpoints and safeguards to remove the
steps that are missing and issues and
configuration in the process from
product creation
to deployment heads to target critical
goals and proven human element gets
removed does making the process less
viable to human errors investments
required for orchestration workflow are
people there must be a confidence in
trust in the team members capabilities
to perform the tasks on their own
culture aligned to a common goal our
high-performing cross-functional teams
and finally process there must be a move
to more automation adaptive and
collaborative structure from more siloed
and manual approach some of the
technologies used here are chef Jenkins
salt puppet and Sibyl and others Amazon
after moving into a more DevOps oriented
approach increased its revenue and
allowed its engineers to scale capacity
up and down keeping the number and
duration of outages reduced it also
transitioned into a more continuous
deployment process
Hey want to become an expert in cloud
computing then subscribe to simpler
Channel and click here to watch more
such videos turn it up and get certified
in cloud computing click here